welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we put you in the know
when it comes to the Snow piercer we're
now at the halfway point of the series
and things are really heating up on
board the train as the harsh reality of
the icy cold world around them slowly
starts to seep into the carriages
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down everything you need to
know about the latest entry including
our thoughts theories and predictions
for the future obviously there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check out episode 5 yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now if you enjoy the video then
please consider subscribing as we do
snowpiercer breakdowns every week and
also drop a thumbs up cuz I know I know
you're a really nice person now though
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of
snowpiercer episode 5 ok so like most
entries in the show episode 5 has a cold
opening that shows Layton in the draw
kronole is being used to sedate him and
as we've learned throughout the season
this causes hallucinations and visions
Layton is clearly suffering from these
and he sees the tale as well as Nikki J
we learn one of the darkest aspects of
Legends past throughout the episode and
it's clear that he's haunted by what
he's done in the night car Audrey cries
over a picture of Nikki and throughout
the episode it becomes evident that she
wants justice for a fallen friend she's
ordering 3rd to play their pot and it
looks like they're slowly starting to
rise up against first simmer to the tail
as we've said so far in our breakdowns I
think that the two sides might actually
unite and then they'll be able to
completely overwhelm those higher up the
Train due to those and first heavily
relying on the denser population down
the carriages the imbalance of wealth is
also showcased in the imbalance of the
population and it definitely suggests
that the next revolution will be led by
both 3rd and the tail after the title
sequence LJ is confined to a cell and
she subtly hints that a powerful parents
will bring vengeance to the tale should
she be found guilty the episode rotates
heavily around her trial and rather the
injustice that comes from it because of
what she knows
LJ is a murderer but due to her position
of power it's over
and she is pardoned for a crimes even
after receiving a guilty verdict I do
believe that this would be the match
that lights the flame to spark of the
writing that will bring the forces of
first toppling down and it's crazy just
how much this show mirrors our world at
the moment I would say that when it was
written it was probably supposed to
share a lot of similarities with the
Rodney King trial during that four
officers that carried out the attack
were acquitted which sent LA spiraling
into rights over the injustice of it
however in light of recent events it
does feel like it still provides
relevant social commentary and it shows
that people will rise up should they
feel like the law
disregards their oppression Melanie asks
Audrey to stop politicizing things
there's a real back-and-forth between
each side but overall it amounts to very
little with Melanie still pretty much
running things no matter what said the
outcome of LJ's innocence almost almost
reminds me of that time that everyone
said that one guy should resign but he
didn't because he probably has a lot of
dirt on the prime minister a bit like LJ
and Melanie but never mind
elsewhere in the episode Bess is getting
a new access chip from Jinju as part of
their relationship this must be the
snowpiercer equivalent of a marriage
visa but I actually think it hints at
what's to come clearly best is very
sympathetic towards the plight of the
tale and it may even be here that grants
them access to the higher ends of the
vehicle when they carry out the revolt
she's sort of playing both sides
throughout this episode I think that she
becomes the wild card on the train that
will bring it all crashing down in the
Folgers car LJ doesn't seem to be taking
things seriously and she even sucks on
our fathers false eye which what the
hell no one dishes messed up
symbolically though I think it shows her
father is blind to what his daughter is
truly capable of we learned that it was
LJ that caused this gross bodily harm to
him and still he was unable to see her
for what she truly was and mother
actually seems to be aware of what she
did however father Folger just acts like
nothing's going on he wishes to protect
her no matter what and you get the
feeling that if she's found guilty it's
clear that things will go badly for
Melanie which puts her in a vulnerable
position in protest of the way that
things are going the night
send up a serving of cockroaches to
first and they're completely aghast over
it whilst this is a terrible thing to
feed someone we actually know that the
tail is often served this through the
form of protein blocks in the film we
learned that the meals were actually
crushed insects and seeing it here to me
metaphorically shows that the tail are
willing to return unto them the same
treatment that they've suffered with for
years
the episode is very much laced with the
feeling that there should be an eye for
an eye and whether you disagree with
that statement or not there's definitely
a feeling and things can't continue the
way they are in the absence of light and
being a character in this episode third
very much sure that they can control
everything should they wish to and
Melanie really struggles with the
balance of power in this entry
Audrey demands that a member of their be
put under the tribunal and Melanie sort
of goes back and forth over whether this
should happen to me this shows that it's
unfair that people who decide the laws
are often the ones that aren't really
affected by them it's easy for first to
agree to making the telly cockroaches as
it's something that they'll never
experience however when it is brought to
them they act in horror highlighting
their hypocrisy Melanie and Bennett get
on and it's clear that the two have an
on and off relationship they remember
life before they trained and how they
miss things and though it's not the
level of the pandemic it did kind of
make me nostalgic we look back on just
how lucky we were to be able to go out
and do things we wanted to this time
last year life has changed a lot and
though it will hopefully go back to
normal soon
I find that it's becoming a lot easier
to relate to people trapped on a 1,001
calling train than I ever thought was
possible
Melanie finally accepts the petition for
a member of 30 to be part of the trial
which puts the Folgers in danger as they
no longer have a complete jury that's on
their side however due to the pardon
this ultimately proves to be meaningless
and it reminds us of the illusion of
power that were often given mr. Fleming
is called up top and he gets to see some
of the finer things in life
Ruth is angered by the paper makers
appointment and it seems like she's
slowly starting to question her idea of
Wilfred as we know Melanie has been
masquerading as him and I think his
suspicions are slowly starting to mount
after this conversation earlier in the
season commander gray also twig that
something was off with him and due to
his speech I think that more and more as
you get into it people are becoming
aware of the truth Jozy continues to
sneak up the train on a break in order
to find out what's actually happened to
Layton and she ends up visiting the
janitor and the truth about the
character's captivity starts to
circulate with the help of the janitor
she breaks into the prison car and frees
him and I'll talk about it later in the
episode but the ramifications of this
are very important and you have to be
aware of them
the trial happens in the first-class car
and I know it wasn't intentional but I
did find this a bit funny I mean the
trains men have a thousand and one cause
and we literally seem to be saying the
same 7 over and over I'm just playing
guys and I know you have a tight budget
but yeah it would be nice to see another
car once in a while anyway the evidence
is very clear and the smoking guns or
other severed penises were all found in
LJ's room which only she has access to
so it becomes clear that she was the one
in control and carrying out the crimes
Audrey cries out that justice must be
done but on a system that's his
corrupted snowpiercer
it's difficult to truly deliver this
when things are this unfair when she's
on the stand
LJ hints that she knows some of Wilfred
secrets and she pretty much says that if
she's brought to justice then these will
all come out LJ is found guilty on all
counts however as we know the system is
only built one way and there's a Bennett
sends a pardon under the guise of
Wilfred in a panic
Melanie Spezza and Josie awakens Layton
he starts to convulse
and this is due to the chronal being
unplugged from him too quickly earlier
in the episode we learn that patients
had to be taken off it slowly and this
may end up leading towards Layton being
compromised mentally in the future
entries obviously he hasn't been on it
for that long but still at the
psychedelic effects will likely carry
over into other parts of the season I
think best discovers Josie and Layton in
a draw and even turns on a co-worker in
order to cover for them she's seen the
corruption firsthand and once more I
think that things are being set up in a
certain way in which she will aid the
tale
Josie takes light into Zara while she
recovers and he likely hide out until he
gets a grip on things the episode
culminates with alg a clearly
thing that she'll be keeping things
quiet as a thank-you for Wilfred or
rather Melanie but that she is a ticking
time bomb that must be dealt with
who knows the Folgers may even end up in
the drawers themselves but it's becoming
clear that melanie is living on borrowed
time
Bess goes to see if the other brakeman
she was with is still lying in the draw
room but he's gone and finally we get
the truth about what Layton and the tale
have had to do to survive they ate a
heart and pottering cannibalism and to
me this eating of one another ties in
with the phrase eat the rich this is
something that's being paid lip-service
to in the show and though they're not
feeding on a rich person here it's clear
that they're willing to eat the rich is
an abbreviation of a saying attributed
is jean-jacques rousseau which says when
the poor have nothing more to eat they
will eat the rich clearly the tailor
willing to do anything and this
repressed memory coming back to Layton
will likely drive him to rise up once
more I don't think they'll be eating
those up the Train but clearly they will
be going against them and this episode
is laced with motifs that hint towards a
coming revolution everything is slowly
falling into place and who knows next
time we might even get the uprising
playing out overall this was another
excellent entry and so far I think the
show has been phenomenal
now obviously I loved hear your thoughts
on the fifth episode and what your
theories are come on below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
series so far and our discussion of
Spike Lee's film defy Bloods you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come check this
after the show in the follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways Cuba today with the channel and
hopefully you see over there very soon
you